la interlingua nació A mediados del
siglo XX se trata de una iniciativa
ideológica de académicos que buscaba
establecer en lenguas universales el
trabajo inició después de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial con esta idea de
compartir un mismo lenguaje pese a los
distintos orígenes para evitar guerras y
conflictos vamos a la conversación con
Carlos balcárceles Ribeiro él es
lingüista español y además es profesor
universitario y se ha hecho viral en
redes sociales Gracias precisamente a
sus videos hablando exclusivamente en
interlingua Carlos sabe y yo Espera que
tú estás en interlingua es una linda
real y lo es internacionalmente de
reconociste congratulaciones
fácilmente
Mire le voy a hablar en español porque
usted sabe que cuando uno está
aprendiendo una lengua duele la cabeza
Así que para nuestros televidentes esta
lengua une el español el italiano el
francés el portugués el inglés y sin
mencionar que también rescata palabras
de muchos más idiomas por qué
Bueno cuando
cuando se diseñó cuando se planificó se
quería una lengua internacional sobre
todo para personas que trabajaban a
nivel internacional En aquel momento
hace 100 años ya había globalización
pero no estaba tan avanzada Entonces se
pensaba sobre todo en personal pues
diplomáticos
abogados abogacía médicos científicos
sobre todo personal universitario que se
movía ya a través de los países y
entonces como la lengua técnica de todas
estas profesiones está basada en el
latín y en el griego se decidió partir
de ahí además se veía que las lenguas la
mayoría de las lenguas más habladas en
el mundo que son europeas y que son
europeas bueno por las razones que
conocemos pues Tenían un gran fondo de
palabras cultas y no tan cultas del
latín Y eso hacía que esta manera de
planificar la lengua pues fuese muy útil
para que fuese entendida muy rápidamente
usted
sentido no sé si sin querer o a
propósito en un experto muy apetecido en
esta interlingua que debería ser fácil
de hablar y como usted decía también
fácil de aprender porque entonces la
poca difusión que ha tenido
Bueno pues porque sin duda se quedó
dentro de que son los ámbitos de estos
profesionales es decir no no hubo una
política de difusión y de uso masivo de
la lengua también cuando se empezó a
practicar interlengua en los años 50 no
había internet y entonces eso dificulta
mucho las cosas el hecho de que sean
pues grupos de profesionales
internacionales y un grupo reducido que
lo que lo que lo quiera hablar y
promocionar y el hecho de que no haya
grandes canales para para difundirlo ya
en esa época esperanto por ejemplo era
una lengua internacional ya importante
bien conocida
y mucha gente que quería aprender pues
una lengua auxiliar e internacional
apostaba por por esperanto y finalmente
el inglés a partir después de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial se convirtió rápidamente
en esa lengua Internacional de la
globalización que
se pretendía que fuese interlingue o
esperando finalmente lo fue el inglés Y
eso pues hace eso que hizo que el que se
quedase una lengua Pues minoritaria sí
mire sabe que nos hemos pasado varias
horas en la redacción de France 24
viendo sus videos de tiktok y
entendiendo todo lo que nos cuenta a
través de ellos y llama mucho la
atención dos cosas primero que tengo
compañeros que
de España o de otros países pueden
entenderlo igual que yo que soy
colombiana por ejemplo Y eso nos hace
pensar Cómo trabajan las conexiones del
cerebro para entender la interlingua ese
bien especial que precisamente entre los
catalanes suena muy parecido
Sí bueno cada cada persona va a percibir
interlingua en función de las lenguas
que conoce o con las que está
familiarizado eso es importante y de
hecho hay muchos comentarios en mis
vídeos de gente que me dice Ah se parece
al italiano o los españoles dicen Se
parecen al italiano Los italianos dicen
se parece al español Los portugueses
dicen que es una mezcla de terreno
español dentro de los españoles también
hay gente que dice que se parece al
Catalán porque reconoce cada uno
reconocen inter lengua marcas de las
lenguas que ya conoce
pero eso es una percepción personal de
cada uno no Es evidente que cuando uno
intenta hacer una lengua planificada
basada en un proceso de estandarización
porque eso es técnicamente lo que se
hace A partir de las principales lenguas
románicas y el inglés pues evidentemente
Pues tendrá parecido con con todas ellas
pero sin embargo el Catalán en principio
no estaba incluido en esas lenguas de
partida y mucha gente reconoce Catalán
dentro de interlingua es curioso Pero
hay muchos italianos también que Me
comentan que cuando hablo que parezco
que hablo benetto que es una lengua
Regional del noreste de Italia de la
región de Venecia esto es curiosísimo
y hablando de espacio Carlos
podríamos decir que le Plus importante
es comunicar es divertirse
es divertirse abusarse
de lengua del proceso de aprendizaje
del beneficios de interlingua del
beneficio es cognitivo de aprender
lengua porque como bolsa disipe nunca
interlingua fase funcionar el cerebro de
una manera especial
del latimidad de propio interlingua es
un síntesis de
lenguashicular multo evento triste
identidad de latín que que odia existe
un pago con abandonante yo pensaba
Pues yo pienso que le agradezco mucho
por esta transmisión de conocimiento que
nos permite replicar aquí en France 24
gracias a usted Carlos